[Musica]
mise la testa sotto le ali quasi
vergognoso di tanti complimenti e tanta
fortuna lui che era stato un brutto
anatroccolo era finalmente ammirato e
felice
con queste parole andersen termina la
favola del brutto anatroccolo e ci
illumina su quanta bellezza possa essere
contenuta nel imperfezione ci ispira
nell'indagare la bellezza contenuta
nella nostra imperfezione
nell'imperfezione di ciascuno di noi
in fondo ci esorta a liberare la
bellezza contenuta nella nostra
imperfezione
secondo la mitologia greca afrodite
secondo quella latina e venere è lei la
dea della bellezza e dell'amore dal suo
sguardo traslucenza nota sensuale che la
rende unica e la sua unicità deriva dal
suo leggero strabismo è quel difettuccio
che la disegna nel mondo in modo non
allineato con gli stereotipi di bellezza
e ne fa la dea della bellezza
il messaggio di questa immagine non
riguarda solo il fatto che in fondo lo
imperfezione vada accettata che magari
vada anche valorizzata c'è qualcosa di
più
venere ci dice che l'imperfezione
rappresenta un vero e proprio dono
quando frequentavo le scuole medie
inferiori non ero certo uno studente
modello ma c'era una materia che più di
altre mi appassionava anzi l'unica
veramente che mi appassionava era
l'antologia epica ricordo che mi
commuovevo leggendo le gesta del mio
eroe preferito ettore per me era l'eroe
perfetto non avevo simpatia per il suo
avversario achille che vedevo come un
superuomo prepotente un gastone
muscoloso poi crescendo ho cambiato
punto di vista iniziato a guardare a
ettore come a un eroe stereotipato come
a un personaggio che fa il perfetto ho
messo fuoco il fatto che forse è la sua
pretesa della perfezione a generare la
sua sconfitta ad opera di un avversario
che non si faceva poi così tanta cura
della sua imperfezione contenuta nel suo
vulnerabile tallone
ho iniziato a immaginare il vanitoso
elettore inchinarsi di fronte all'umile
achille in giappone secondo una tecnica
e una tradizione chiamata in su g i vasi
rotti vengono riparati incollando le
diverse parti con una colla ricca d'oro
questa tecnica produce un effetto
paradossale sorprendente e cioè la parte
più preziosa del vaso diventa la sua
crepa e ci suggerisce che davvero forse
la crepa è la parte più preziosa anche
per quanto ci riguarda e che forse
davvero i nostri talenti sono contenuti
nelle nostre crepe e cioè nei nostri
limiti e che forse i nostri limiti altro
non sono che talenti non ancora
finalizzati l'idea della crepa come
valore non appartiene solo alla cultura
giapponese anche a quella africana
una favola africana racconta di una
donna che ogni mattina si reca al fiume
da prendere l'acqua per il villaggio e
prende l'acqua e la trasporta in due
vasi di terracotta che tiene sospesi
all'estremità di un bastone che tiene
sulle spalle un'immagine tipicamente
africana ma non porta al villaggio due
vasi d'acqua ma solo un vaso e mezzo già
che mentre il vaso di destra e
perfettamente integro il vaso di
sinistra è crepato appunto e perde acqua
lungo il tragitto dopo due anni dice la
favola il vaso crepato trova il coraggio
di parlare alla donna e le dice mi sento
molto frustrato perché mi vergogno di
saper fare solo la metà di quello che
dovrei la donna continua il suo cammino
sorride al vaso crepato egli rivolge una
domanda gli chiede hai mai fatto caso
quanti fiori nascono sul lato sinistro
del sentiero questo è perché io
conoscendo la tua caratteristica pianto
dei semi e tutti i giorni l'inaf noi
raccogliamo questi fiori e coloriamo il
nostro villaggio termina la favola
dicendo le parole delle ultime parole
della donna al vaso che sono se tu non
fossi come sei il nostro villaggio non
sarebbe così bello è una favola e una
storia un'immagine una metafora che ci
toccano il profondo perché di nuovo ci
mette in contatto con la possibilità che
grazie alle nostre crete possiamo fare
cose speciali in fondo il vaso crepato
sa fare una cosa che il vaso inter
non sa fare possiamo quindi iniziare a
guardare alle nostre crepe con spirito
benevolo e se iniziamo a fare questo
forse impariamo a guardare con spirito
benevolo anche le crepe degli altri
non è un caso se la stessa cultura da
cui è derivata quella favola fa derivare
anche un proverbio che dice appunto
quando due bufali combattono chi
sicuramente perde nella terra che
calpestano noi calpestiamo troppa terra
così propensi come siamo a di vendicare
contro le crepe del mondo a recriminare
contro i malvagi al potere che non le
riparano ma il mondo non diventa come
vorremmo che fosse in ragione del fatto
che noi recriminiamo contro le sue crete
il mondo migliore grazie alla nostra
capacità di scovare il bello e dargli
spazio
questa idea ci riguarda anche nelle
nostre relazioni personali e perché non
sentimentali
quante relazioni di coppia degradano e
si interrompono a causa del fatto che
qualcuno pretenda che l'altro diventi
come vorrebbe che fosse ma così come il
mondo non diventa come vorremmo che
fossero neanche le persone diventano
come vorremmo che fossero il package va
accettato o rifiutato all inclusive
l'unica via ancora una volta è scovare
il bello e dargli spazio
l'unica via è intravedere la luce
nell'ombra e aiutare il proprio compagno
la propria compagna ampliare la sua luce
contenuta nella sua ombra
questa idea ci è raccontata dal tau che
rappresenta molto bene questo concetto
in modo assolutamente semplice ma
efficacissimo nel tao possiamo vedere il
giorno e la notte la luce londra il
maschio e una femmina la vita la morte
la vittoria la sconfitta
possiamo anche vedere la luce e l'ombra
contenute in ciascuno di noi e il tau ci
segnala una cosa ci segnala che nel
chiarore è contenuto il germe della
tenebra e nell'ombra e contenuto lo
spiraglio della luce è il viatico alla
nostra crescita personale
consiste proprio nel cogliere quello
spiraglio di luce contenuto nell'ombra e
dargli spazio per fare questo occorre
molto coraggio
occorre molto coraggio perché dare
spazio a quello spiraglio di luce
presuppone accettare l'ombra in cui
quello spiraglio sorge e quell'ombra è
fatta delle parti di noi che ci fanno
più paura che consideriamo socialmente
meno convenienti per dare spazio a
quello spiraglio di luce occorre saper
adottare comportamenti non convenzionali
correndo così il rischio di apparire
anche grotteschi e talora ridicoli dice
va bene
marilyn monroe quando affermava la
pazzia e genialità l'imperfezione e
bellezza ma sopra
tutto è molto meglio essere
assolutamente ridicoli che assolutamente
noiosi adottando questo atteggiamento
noi potremo scegliere di abbracciare i
nostri limiti e le nostre carenze con lo
stesso spirito con cui un padre sa
abbracciare il suo figliolo difficile di
cui finalmente coglie il valore potremo
così un giorno riparto rir c intorno ai
nostri magici strabismi al ai nostri
vulnerabili talloni e alle nostre crepe
preziose e forse quel giorno anche noi
potremmo chinare la testa sotto le
nostre nuove ali per regalarci
compiutamente al mondo per ciò che
davvero siamo
[Applauso]